[Music]
mic sell me on Ghost Recon quick do you
uh like I said Miguel concepción review
was up he gave it a seven out of ten on
gamespot we had a review in progress up
like the week before hand but you know
there's a big game apparently like
bigger than Miguel expected a lot of us
expected yes super lot of content yeah I
mean here's what I can say if you plan
to play this co-op with friends you will
probably have a good time it's still
janky there's still a lot of like you
know Ubisoft things like unlocking not
unlocking different parts of map because
it's all open right away but you'll find
Intel do different missions but if you
play by yourself it just feels like a
not as good Metal Gear Solid 5 like yeah
nearly as good Metal Gear Solid 5 that's
the comparison of ways making and maybe
it's because it's this military stick
open-world shooter but what in your
experience does that have wait that
comparison with Metal Gear Solid 5 I
think it does
I mean Metal Gear Solid is a little more
wacky right in its own sort of weird
Kojima way while this is tries to be
more grounded but it kind of isn't at
the same time and it just doesn't
doesn't have that sort of charm not that
it's going for that I don't know it just
like the direction doesn't make a lot of
sense at times but like it's very its
tactical like you can choose how you
want to approach things you can drive
any vehicle fly any vehicle so there's a
lot of room for experimentation but at
the same time I'd rather be playing
Metal Gear Solid 5 wouldn't we all is
that one of those multiplayer games
that's fun because of the people you
play it with or like is it does it do
anything to facilitate a good co-op
experience I mean I wouldn't play with
random people like that's definitely a
way to play I think it does a good job
of like putting you with games with
other people and like I don't know like
you can warp to your teammates so that
makes it easier and you can kind of plan
things out but I wouldn't want to play
this with randos because they'll
probably just run in and screw things up
without that sort of communication it
would be tough and Plus like this game
is kind of screwy I'd say so playing
with friends and screwing around is
probably the best way to play that's
just having fun so when I hear even when
you're playing with like a team your
friends you
here the voiceovers of the characters
that they're portraying that's really
weird and like they're not even really
portraying them because those characters
are like set characters in the game like
they're your squadmates they're supposed
to have personalities but then they get
replaced by your your friends who are
just like random crazy-looking
characters but you still hear the voices
of your teammates which is do they like
make it sound like it's over walkie
talkie in that scenario or does it still
sound like they're just right next to
you I don't remember I'm pretty sure it
still sounds like they're right next to
you it's it's really weird it's like you
take a place
yeah you take you like infiltrate like a
cocaine oh yeah hideouts well how does
it compare to the division right because
this seems to be the thing that Tom
Clancy games have been doing lately
aside from Rainbow six siege but the
division being a new IP was this you
know co-op focused open-world more kind
of like MMO leaning almost like destiny
kind of blend of shooter in MMO whereas
Ghost Recon like you said seems like
it's going for that open-world emergence
of a metal of your solid or you know
like a breath of the wild but here we
find ourselves another open-world game
from Ubisoft how does it compare the
division like what are your experiences
between the two games do you put a fair
amount of the division right uh I don't
play a whole lot of division I played
enough to say that I think this game is
very different than the division I mean
it's still like similar sort of idea
like you know like military shooter sort
of even though division wasn't really
military but like there's no bullet
sponges it's not really a loot grind so
much like you still find different
weapons but you're not like oh I want to
get that I figured with the colors green
purple blue whatever you're not like
looking for like rare loot necessarily
yeah what guys just kill him or move on
yeah I also hate your haircut
what like as far as the story goes from
what I've seen and from what everybody
said don't ask me what it's about
because I have no idea how I mean that
you're just essentially trying to take
down what you're in is a Bolivia Blanca
yeah yeah and you're trying to take down
the drug cartel which have you seen the
movie traffic or literally anything else
about the drug trade you know it's not
gonna work
generic South American drug cartel right
yeah the Bolivian government I think
today like it came out that they've
filed a formal complaint against Ubisoft
for the way that portrayed Bolivia no
are you kidding
know what this is so I don't know II be
pissed too
I don't know if you guys remember but
when I think Rainbow Six Vegas came out
Las Vegas was pretty annoyed with them
so maybe you V stuff just likes to piss
off Vegas entire cities yeah I haven't
watchdogs to that everyone was kind of
like yeah that's about right
well you'd like a microcosm for San
Francisco yes just like a dude jumping
out of bushes on what's the bush guy
plant guy in Fisherman's Wharf ish guy
man passed away oh he did yeah you went
out there might be someone there he was
like taking this place with the original
guy but an imposter there's like six
people lining up to I got the call honey
we're bringing up Joni she's ready it's
her time but from what I've heard
gostrey cons gostrey cons dialog kind of
leans on frat boy humor from what Aaron
said yeah I won't repeats a lot of dick
jokes but like it has like no place in
the game like and it doesn't make sense
it's like but why would you say that
like there's it's really weird isn't
there like one like kind of like vulgar
phrase that they repeat like throughout
yeah see holster which I don't know what
me with that like a whole or I mean I'm
not gonna say the actual work oh oh no
yeah they sit like you get shot oh my
god holster and I'm like what that
doesn't works you see where do you be
talking about but yeah I know I know
okay the phallic one you don't get that
I mean I did it
is it chicharrón is that it that's it
but I just don't understand why they'd
be saying like I don't know yeah it's
weird not really like an expletive it's
more of a name you would call someone
yeah it's an insult but like depending
on that's not it like that's the one you
hear a lot that's the one Aaron in the
office likes to talk about but there
there's a lot more that just like like
don't make any sense at all he said
there was like a lot of like dicta
yeah like okay do you feel like the
actual narrative is worth pursuing to
get through the game or you know or like
interested in [ __ ] or I yeah I mean
it seems like the way the narrative is
built is that you're not really gonna
pay attention much to it you know like
it's kind of just meant to do it your
own pace do what you want kind of screw
around like see what your friends are
doing like basically when you join a
co-op game you can read you old missions
you can do any mission in any order yes
they were kind of going for that like
like even with this story that sort of
emergent gameplay where you kind of like
do things as you please yeah so and the
story suffers because of that which I
mean I wouldn't play uh I wouldn't play
this Ghost Recon because I want a good
story though like you play cuz you want
to screw around tom clancy's an author
man it's true but we did that lobby
segment a few weeks ago about like our
Tom Clancy and fluting their identity
because it feels like it wasn't yeah are
you on it no no I think I called you out
and told you I told people no you said
we're talking about whether we're
talking about whether we actually think
because we're able succeed started off
as a tactical shooter and I think that
actually I like most exceeds a lot just
seems like they're kind of pursuing
these trends now and after playing more
Ghost Recon and seeing how the division
kind of seemed to be catching on that
destiny flavor of game does it seem like
Ghost Recon is kind of pursuing other
developers trends rather than trying to
set it apart from itself I'd say so I
mean I see it reminds me more of Grand
Theft Auto 5 into the division kind of
like that GTA online GTA online has
become something completely different
now at this point it's very there's a
lot to it and I know people who still
play it like can vouch for that but
Ghost Recon just seems to focus on coop
but it's very much like screwing around
like you do in GTA 5 okay GTA online
well if you want to know more about
Ghost Recon wildlands we have our full
review up on gamespot miguel concepción
gave it a 7 out of 10 you can go read
that we also have streams we've done
which we've archived on GameSpot or
YouTube you can go watch a lot of video
content we've done in the game if you
want to know more it's been out for a
week now as of yesterday like a week so
let us know what you think hit us up on
Twitter tell us what you think of the
game if you've been playing that amid
all the other releases some of which
we're gonna get to today but leave your
thoughts in the comments and we'll try
to respond
[Music]